moment that would just lead to plan b
kicking in
but he did make clear that it was about
the nhs coping nhs being
under pressure and if it is
uh no longer sustainable
if we're going to that direction and
getting there quite soon i think that's
the moment where you would see plan b
being introduced although of course as
we say businesses who would have to
invoke vaccine pass boards that wouldn't
be immediate there would be
a week's
notice but i suppose this is really
about uh sanji java making it clear they
have many options for different
eventualities there is a confidence but
we know
the government have been confident in
the past and found infection rates
rising at a very severe level what will
be at the center though of what
restaurants will want to communicate
today as ever will be the vaccine he
said that's the core of his strategy
that's the first line of defense so a
lot of the
uh sort of encouragement i think will be
to people who've not got vaccinated to
get their vaccines for over 50s to get
their third doses and for parents of 12
to 15 year olds to also encourage their
children to get vaccinated not just for
their own health but for the health of
the whole country and indeed what the
government have also touched on as part
of their plan is that kovac scheme
ensuring the rest of the world gets
vaccinated and therefore that would
hopefully mean that variants which
appear
when the virus changes adapts in places
often whether high infection rates the
variance can be kept to a minimum
minimum and nothing too dangerous could
come into this country that's also why
we should have an update in the coming
days it's the government's strategy on
borders that also is expected to change
i i wouldn't expect necessarily boris
johnson to touch on borders today i
think vaccines sarah will be at the core
of his message today yeah i think
october the first was the date set out
by sajid javid for more information on
travel restrictions wasn't it uh joe um
in terms of the booster roll out how
quickly will it get underway
well in a matter of days as early as uh
next week was uh one revelation today
but clearly if there are people who can
get vaccinated sooner than that i'm sure
the nhs will
uh work hard to achieve that boosters
are for the over 50s although over 70s
are the priority those who work in the
care sector and therefore with
vulnerable people or the nhs should also
be getting the boosters of course there
have been others including dame sarah
gilbert who was the person behind the
octet uh asgenica vaccine who've
actually said that boosts are not the
best
uh use of the millions of doses still
held by the uk government and actually
to help the world recover and to
minimize the threat of variance as as
i've discussed actually those doses
would be better off being sent to
developing countries of course the
government points out they have already
put
many millions of doses into the kovac
scheme uk government is one of the
biggest donors to that scheme and
therefore they believe we are doing
our part i think though people will be
wanting to accept their boosters
certainly the uptake of vaccines is is
pretty high in the uk certainly compared
to
many other western nations and
that is a is clearly a relief for boris
johnson he doesn't have to try quite as
hard as perhaps joe biden does in the us
to
encourage people and in in some cases in
the states of course force people if
they're working for the government to
get uh double jabs it'll also be
interesting to hear what the difference
is between the scientists and the
politicians boris johnson has generally
tried to be far more optimistic
in these news events
natural boosters he's not a do monger by
nature whereas professor whitty in some
extent sir patrick valance are often
slightly more cautious
looking towards possible worst-case
scenarios looking at the data
very carefully and worrying about what
could suddenly happen sudden changes
that could go in a negative direction
for the country
we are expecting that news conference
get underway any moment uh joe they are
running slightly late but we have been
given our one minute warning and it is
an in-person news conference from the
prime minister and uh the chief medical
officer and chief scientific advisor
back face to face for journalists in the
room but
we heard today in that plan b there is a
contingency for people to reverting to
working from home
yeah clearly they want us to see a
journalist in that news conference room
because we are moving to life similar
you know back to normal they want to i
think show
as they didn't during uh the pandemic
quite what is happening anyway mr
johnson is coming into the room yeah
here we are the prime minister professor
chris witte and patrick valance
to set out our plan
for managing kovid this autumn and
winter
and i want you to cast your mind back
exactly a year and think where we were
last september as schools went back and
the colder months approached
because in one way our position today is
actually more challenging we have higher
levels of daily cases thousands more
but in many other crucial respects the
british people
all of us collectively and individually
are incomparably better placed to fight
the disease
we have more than 80 percent of all over
16s now double jab double vaccinated and
we have covered antibodies in around 90
percent of the adult population and
those vaccines are working we've seen
the extraordinary vaccine-induced falls
in deaths and serious disease and
depending on your age you're up to nine
times
more likely to die sadly if you're
unvaccinated than if you've had both
jabs
and
the result of this vaccination campaign
is that we have one of the most free
societies
and one of the most open economies in
europe and that's why when i was
sticking with our strategy in essence
we're going to keep going we will
continue to offer testing we'll continue
to urge everyone to be sensible to be
responsible
wash your hands use ventilation
consider wearing a face covering in
crowded places
with people that you don't know
stay at home if you feel unwell
download and use the app
and we're investing massively in our nhs
to meet the pressures of covid with an
additional 5.4 billion in england over
the next six months and that's on top of
almost 36 billion over the next three
years to help our nhs recover and fix
the long-standing problems of social
care as well
as i was saying last week and were
helping to vaccinate the world
with 100 million doses for developing
countries by
next june i think this country should be
proud uh continue to be very proud that
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine remains
the workhorse of global immunization
and we will keep
further measures
in reserve
plan b
we do not see the need now to proceed
for instance with mandatory
certification uh but we'll continue
to work with the many businesses that
are getting ready uh such a scheme in in
indeed over 200 events have already used
uh covid certification voluntarily
and it's it's just not sensible to rule
out completely this kind of option
now
when we must face the fact that it might
still make the difference between
keeping businesses open at full capacity
or not we will also keep open the option
of mandating face coverings as they as
they have elsewhere or advising people
again to work from home reflecting the
fact that
when you've got a large proportion of
the country as we have now with immunity
then smaller changes can make a bigger
difference and give us the confidence
that we don't need to go back to the
lockdowns of the past and of course
we'll continue to update
our advice to you
based on the latest data
but in the meantime
we are confident in the vaccines that
have made such a difference
to our lives
and we're now intensifying that effort
offering jobs to 12 to 15 year olds on
the advice of the chief medical officers
who've given that advice
based
on the health
well-being
and educational prospects
of the children themselves
and
for
over 50s and the
under 50s who are at risk or more at
risk we're now motoring ahead with the
booster program a third dose
six months after your second dose and so
that's going to mean we're going to be
building even higher walls of
immunization
of vaccine protection in this country
and the uk government has procured at
scale
jabs for every part of the uk and
we'll be sending doses to the devolved
administrations in scotland wales
and northern ireland
covid
is still out there the disease sadly
still remains a risk but i'm confident
that we can keep going with our plan to
turn jabs jab jabs into jobs jobs jobs
and protect the gains that we've made
together
thanks very much i'm going to ask
chris i think to do the sites chris
first slide please
um the first slide is the number of
people testing positive for covid uh 19
in the uk uh as everybody i think knows
there was a significant
dip
during the middle part of the year
started to rise uh in june july there
was a peak which then uh eased off but
there's been a gradual drifting up over
the last few weeks it's stabilized over
the last week but i think we should be
careful neither to over interpret nor
under interpret this at the moment
things are stabilized to some extent but
we are as i'll come on to going into
more difficult period of the year next
slide please
and the number of people in hospital
with kovid has inevitably mirrored this
and what we've seen is again a gradual
drifting up
of the number of people in hospital it
is not anywhere near yet uh the point it
was in the first
peak
and
in the subsequent peaks at the early
part last end of last year and beginning
of this year but the there is a general
a gentle general upward trend uh
variable around different parts of the
country
next slide please
the good news of course is that the
number of people who are dying following
a positive test for covid19 is
significantly lower proportional to the
number of cases than it was at the end
of last year in the beginning of this
year but these numbers again are not
trivial
by any means every one of these of
course is a tragedy for the family so
around 140
deaths in terms of the seven day average
and again this is gradually drifting up
but very slowly broadly this is flat to
just drifting up
next slide please
and the number of people who've received
a vaccination for covid uh is also
increasing uh both for second doses uh
people who've previously been vaccinated
getting their second dose to
really strengthen their protection
and also for first doses
so those are the trends and i think
they've been widely uh circulated uh in
in various media outlets over the last
few weeks but that was just to bring
people up to date next slide please
we did however want to add just three
additional slides
because i think these make a point and
reinforce the points that the prime
minister has just made
this first slide these are public health
england data uh shows uh the number of
people with covert 19 coming to
emergency care
within 28 days of positive tests that
just means with covid in most cases
that led to a hospital admission by
vaccination status
and what you can see is that in every
age
there is a very substantially smaller
proportion
risk of doing this if you are vaccinated
than if you're not vaccinated in every
age
and actually if you uh look if you sort
of just do a
very crude look at the numbers
someone who is in their 30s and
unvaccinated is running about the same
risk as someone in their 70s who is
vaccinated
it's that level of difference
and i really want to reinforce why
people of every age should be trying to
get vaccinated and one of the most
depressing things for doctors
including myself is talking to people
who have just chosen not to get
vaccinated because it wasn't convenient
to that particular moment and you see
them being wheeled down to intensive
care and you know this was a very
serious uh problem as a result of them
not being vaccinated we really must
encourage everybody we know to get
vaccinated the great majority people who
have not been vaccinated not because
they're against vaccination but because
they just haven't got to doing it and
we're about to enter winter winter is
coming and people really should take
this seriously
next slide please
and this is even more clear if you look
at the mortality rates which again
are very starkly different between those
who are vaccinated and those who are not
vaccinated so i really would encourage
and i'm sure all of you would encourage
everybody we know to get vaccinated and
then double vaccinated so the three
uh sort of layers of defense from
vaccination
uh two new uh the first one children
and young people 12 to 15 which we
talked about yesterday uh today a
discussion of people getting their
booster doses who've already had two
vaccines and getting a third but the
third and arguably the most important is
that people who've had no vaccines
should be encouraged to get their first
and then their second vaccination this
is really critical
next slide please
and the final point uh really with the
data is this is a comparison of where we
are now and this reinforces very much
the point the prime minister made at the
beginning of his uh his uh opening
remarks in 2021 in the orange line and
along the bottom is the dates
and where we were in 2020
and what you can see in this is that
this time last year we were only
beginning to get the takeoff that you
see in or in the in autumn uh and into
winter
and we're entering the autumn and winter
period at a much higher level in terms
of number of cases in terms of number of
hospitalizations and in terms of number
of deaths than we were this time last
year
and the reason that is possible for that
to be
to be happening and the nhs under
extreme pressure but not at the point
where it was by any means
at the turn of the year is because of
vaccination but we are entering the
winter with this reasonably high level
it wouldn't take many doubling times to
get into trouble and therefore people
still need to take this disease very
seriously because i don't think you need
a medical degree to know that autumn and
winter is when respiratory viruses are
hugely advantaged
flu and others as people um come
together indoors
windows closed and so on so it was
really just a reinforcement to people if
you've not had your vaccination now is a
very good time uh to do so thank you
very much thanks very much chris patrick
anything to add to that let's go to
questions there thanks very much let's
go to questions for
from the public first michael from
dorset
uh michael asks the government suggested
march 2020 that twenty thousand deaths
from kobe 19 would be a good result why
then is the pm doing not doing anything
to prevent even more unnecessary deaths
well michael i'm not certain that uh
that was what we uh suggested but what
we are doing of course with all our
policies is to and everything we've done
since the beginning of the of the
pandemic
is to prevent uh unnecessary deaths
everyone has been a tragedy uh but i
think i'm right in in saying that the i
think i saw a statistic from public
health england saying that the
vaccination program
alone had saved uh perhaps a hundred
thousand lives uh maybe 120 000 uh lives
and and that's why uh what chris has
just said about uh getting your jab is
is so
absolutely crucial um
thank you michael uh kirsty from leeds
can the government advise on when strict
travel rules will ease further for those
that are fully vaccinated
and advise on what determines the
country's list at the moment travelers
are confused about where they can go uh
when countries that have low covered
rates and good uh vaccinations are still
red uh thanks very much
uh kirsty i i i
i appreciate the people uh are very
frustrated about
the
the travel rules but it is vital that we
do uh whatever we can to stop uh the
virus being being reimported and
particularly to to control new variants
so when they're at risk of of coming in
that's why we have the rules that's why
we have the red lists and i know that
travelers have been frustrated this
summer and having to to take tests in
order to to do it but i think it is a
reasonable to ask people uh to do that
to help protect the the population uh
we'll be saying a lot more shortly
kirsty about the the traffic light
system about simplifying it and about
what we can do to make the burdens of
testing uh less
onerous for those who are uh coming back
into uh coming back in into the country
uh kirsty but that's that that will be
coming shortly let's go to uh
questions from the media vicky young
from bbc news
uh prime minister could just start on
both of us by extending our condolences
to you and your family
thank you very much
um could you tell us in what
circumstances you would impose those
extra restrictions your plan b do you
have a number of cases a number of
hospital admissions which would mean
that we've passed that threshold and a
similar question really to um professor
whitty and sir patrick when do you think
extra restrictions
should be imposed
well because because
sorry first of all thank you very much
for uh for your for your kind your kind
words and uh
um to many others who have said the same
but on on your
your point about about uh
plan b and when it and and and how and
what the trigger might be for uh
for that i think that just bear in mind
what we're trying to prevent
and that is the overwhelming of the
of the nhs and that that's got to remain
the uh the objective um
the there are uh all sorts of data that
we'll continue to study as we have
throughout the pandemic in deciding uh
what the the risks are what the what the
state of the disease is we'll keep you
updated about where we are uh you've
heard the exact state of things at the
moment and we're confident we can
proceed with
with plan a but i think what i would
stress about plan b
is that it contains a number of
different shots in the in the locker and
you wouldn't necessarily play them uh
all at once far from it you'd uh you'd
want to do things
in a graduated
way
and i just
emphasized what i think patrick has said
many times that we're now in a situation
when because so many of the population
have some degree of immunity
smaller changes uh in uh in the guide
smaller changes in the way we're asking
people to behave can have a bigger
impact and and a smaller tilt on the
tiller if you want can uh effect a
bigger change in the in the direction of
the of the pandemic and maybe uh patrick
can uh can say more about that uh if you
want that do you want to
yeah i mean we've got high levels of
immunity now and and and if as chris
said we can get everybody who's not
vaccinated to be vaccinated so that's
the most important thing we can do there
are five million or so people who are
eligible for vaccines now who haven't
been vaccinated and trying to persuade
those people it's the right thing to do
to get vaccinated would make a
significant difference
so getting that immunity up
means that then the barrier against
rises is that much greater if you think
about where we are now with infection
rates and the openness that we've
currently got
if you tried to do this six months ago
the number of cases and deaths and
hospitalizations would be through the
roof
so the immunity is really important to
keep this down and allows
lighter measures to be
put in place to keep it and keep it
under control
that said
the things to look at are
hospitalizations
they are really really important as a
marker of when things are going in the
wrong direction and the relationship
between cases and hospitalizations
because one of the things that vaccines
has done is made that relationship
really much less
so if you saw that changing again that
would be a cause for concern so those
are things to look at
and the
final thing to say is that the
principles which have been really clear
i think right the way across the world
are
when you make a move you have to go
earlier than you think you want to you
have to go harder than you think you
want to and you need to make sure you've
got the right geographical coverage so
if this goes in the wrong direction and
cases go up followed by hospitalizations
it's important that the measures are put
in place early enough and they're
significant enough
thanks let's add slightly to that pm i
mean i think
in addition to what uh pm and patrick
has said i mean the two there are three
things which i think is worth looking at
the first of which is the absolute
numbers going to hospital
the second though is the rate of change
a gradual drift up is one thing if you
suddenly saw a very rapid increase then
you have to
consider taking earlier action and the
third of which is the overall state of
the nhs which of course does vary over
the year and as you go into winter they
tend to be greater pressures so these
are all the kinds of things that will
need to be taken into account but no one
is claiming there is a good number we
would all like the numbers to be as low
as possible but in terms of what might
trigger change those are the things
which i think are the most likely
good thank you very much uh robert
pearson itv
and obviously we're all
relieved the
way in which
the vaccine reduces severe
disease actually i've just myself
recovered from uh kobe double backs um
but um as your chart showed
numbers going in hospital are five times
what they were a year ago
sorry four times actually deaths are
five times what they were a year ago and
as you pointed out we're about to get
colder weather we're gonna be indoors
more kids are going back to school
what is the argument for not taking mild
suppressive measures now as a
preventative measure and
separately on boosters um you'll have
seen the lancet paper uh
scientists from the who american fda and
others and we've seen what sarah gilbert
said in oxford um
the argument for in that in in in there
the argument for boosters is not
overwhelming and many of those people
think we'd be doing a better job sending
those vaccines to countries that haven't
got any vaccines at all at the moment
places like africa
why do you disagree with that judgment
because it is an important
judgment difference
well the scientist for the latter one
and all of you for the question of why
not take you know prophylactic action
even of a mild sort now
i'll just say to you robert on that uh
because the the vaccines have made a
huge difference in uh reducing uh
mortality the ratio of cases to uh to
serious disease and deaths is is vast
and we are continuing to advise
everybody uh to be sensible and
unresponsible so so plan a what what
we're doing at the moment uh continues
to you know continue to
think about using a face covering in a
confined space uh when you're meeting
people you you don't know uh wash your
hands use ventilation uh get a test stay
at home if you feel unwell
these are these are very very important
restrictions that i think people
or ways we behave responsibly
that people should continue to maintain
but i think that's the right balance
given where the the pandemic is at the
moment and given what we've been able to
achieve and i think that the priority
should be for the fight you know there
are literally five million uh more
people who could get a vaccination uh
and uh who haven't yet done so
and those are the people that i think we
should be encouraging now uh to uh to
come on come forward get get your jab uh
it will be good for you uh for the
the numbers the reasons that uh chris
has set out you're overwhelmingly more
likely sadly to to die or to suffer
serious disease if you if you haven't
been vaccinated and so vaccination i
think should be the the key thing we we
advocate
you know to add to that so um firstly on
the measures
i if we had a situation where everybody
was back to behaving as they did prior
to
march 2020
we would have a much higher rate than we
do at the moment
so actually people are taking measures
everybody's taking on everybody's thing
but lots of people are taking measures
they're meeting with fewer people good
research demonstrate that many people
are wearing masks in crowded places and
all the other things that the prime
minister's talked about so it's not that
we're not taking measures there are
quite a lot of measures and lots of
people probably the great majority
people still are taking some or a lot of
measures to reduce the risk that they
and other people get infected in
addition to being vaccinated which as
the prime minister said is the most
important thing so
i think you shouldn't just say there's
nothing happening that clearly already
is on boosters i think it's important to
separate out two things which i think if
they get conflated leads to uh confusion
the first one which everyone would agree
with and the prime minister said in his
remarks is everybody agrees we want to
get vaccines out all around the world
including low-income countries
that is an absolute moral imperative it
is also an absolute practical imperative
for everybody and everybody agrees that
that isn't a contentious point
the second question is is there some
waning of immunity that means that a
third
dose a booster dose is a sensible thing
to do and i think there is now
reasonably good evidence that that is
the case
uh the uk has taken and sense a
middleway on this
led by the jcvi it has neither said no
boosters at all because there is
evidence of waning particularly at the
top end of the age range and in those
who've got pre-existing health
conditions and those are the groups that
jc dive
have actually recommended it in addition
to health and social care workers
because of the chance that this is going
to reduce the probability they will
infect others so that there's a very
good logic but they've not gone all the
way of recommending universal boosters
for everybody so they've taken a middle
path uh which some nations are gone for
but the logic of the boosters for the uk
is i think is clear and science-based
and the ethical imperative as well as
the overall need to do that i think is
widely agreed and those two i think are
separate discussions if we suddenly
stopped having boosters
uh given uh the particular vaccines
we're using which are the mrna ones with
very ultra cold uh cold chains uh
actually at the moment not long very
long shelf lives the idea that's somehow
going to transform the situation in
low-income countries i think is a
misunderstanding i think those are
separate issues but both are important
yeah just to build on that and i agree
completely with what chris has said
if you think about the degree of
immunity we've got and the levels of
behavioral restriction that people have
imposed upon themselves so people aren't
meeting as many people we know contact
patterns are still quite a long way down
compared to where they were but they are
changing quite fast the faster they
change the more pressure this is going
to come under and that may well lead to
a significant increase
if you look at
go just across the channel countries
where you've got similar levels of
immunity and some higher degrees of
restriction what you can see is that the
cases are going down so you can see
we're sort of at that pivot point where
things are
flattish at the moment
if they go up quickly then as i said
you've got to go early in terms of
getting on top of it you can't wait till
it's late because you have to do more so
that's sort of where we are on that
and on the boosters
the waning of immunity is clear it's
it's greater for infection than it is
for the waning against hospitalizations
and deaths so they're held holding up
very well and i want to just say
the the really important point is these
vaccines are really good they are really
effective vaccines far more effective
than we could dared of hoped for at the
beginning so this is this is uh
some waning and um that waning is most
evident in the people who are at most at
risk and so getting on and getting that
topped up does two things
it gives a very high level of antibody
coverage and it probably broadens the
coverage across variants as well
because you've got such high response so
i think it's a sensible thing to do jcvi
i've considered it very carefully and i
think their recommendation is a very
sensible one
great thanks gary gibbon channel 4.
thank you very much um
professor whitty um you talked a bit
about the metrics for how we might
decide
we've got to move from plan a to plan b
lock down light maybe um what about the
trigger is it most likely do you think
that it'll be a new variant that would
actually change the game
here is that is that the real game
changer that you'd be expecting to
transform the horizon there and when the
prime minister said uh he would uh urge
people to consider wearing a face mask
in crowded indoor places you say we're
in a very serious condition is
is considering it enough and prime
minister
on vaccine passports you said in this
building in july you serve notice that
you're planning to bring them in
we really planning to bring them in
we're just trying to get the numbers up
of younger vaccination we've then had
lots of other mixed messaging which
isn't great in public health what's
going on
uh thank you uh in terms of new variants
certainly new variants are one of the
things we need to look seriously at now
of course variants are happening the
whole time have always happened
what we need with the worry would be one
that can escape from the vaccination so
the delta variant is a very bad variant
i mean let's be very clear it's a very
bad variant and that's the reason we've
had such trouble in the last year as as
every country around the world
we have not faced a winter with the
delta variant
so it is possible that the combination
of winter events plus the delta variant
which is highly transmissible could lead
to a situation where
on the basis of the data ministers
decided that they wanted to trigger all
or some of uh the plan b as the prime
minister's laid out so i think you have
to take it as it comes i think anybody
you can say
with confidence they know how this is
going to work over the next few months
has not fully understood i think the
range of possible ways this could happen
but certainly were there to be a variant
that was both transmissible and escaped
from the vaccines that would put us in a
new situation and no doubt the prime
minister would come back and explain
where he wished to go at that point in
time but we're not at that point in time
i think the moment our expectation is
the delta variant but over autumn and
winter is what we face at the moment
and then um in terms of uh masks i think
uh my previous uh suggestion to people
remains my view which is if you are in a
crowded environment particularly for an
indoor space wearing a mask is a way of
helping protect other people being
vaccinated really helps protect them but
it's not a complete protection people
can get infected and they can transmit
vaccinated that's much lower probability
to both of those wearing a mask helps to
reduce that it's not something you need
to concern yourself so much if you're
outdoors in highly ventilated areas
and the other area where i think it is
sensible is if actually you've got
people around you who wish you to do so
either because they've got medical
conditions or simply because that is
their desire i consider it an issue of
common courtesy there is there are a
number of issues situations you would
want to wear a mask but that's not
that's not universal
and it's a recommendation it's not
something which the government uh has
put into regulation
excellent thank you and just gary on
your point about uh kobe's certification
and
vaccine passports uh
as it were i really do defend these in
in principle i think it was right to
to set it set out in july that we could
go forward uh with with those measures
actually what what has happened uh is i
mean if you think about a year ago where
we were
you know last september can you imagine
if we'd had then uh covered uh
certification uh we would have been able
uh with that that tool to keep open uh
businesses that that had been forced to
close and uh that were going through an
absolutely wretched time it would they
would have been a total uh game changer
lifesaver uh uh
last year uh and so i think that they're
they're important to uh they're
important part of our of our our our
repertoire um
and it's great that
loads of events have been working uh to
use them people have been making the
system work
um
and you know
as i said earlier on we may get we may
because of uh where the the disease gets
to we may we may have to to use them in
a more in a more thorough going way we
reserve the right uh to come back to you
and say we think that that's going to be
to be necessary i do think the public
understand that uh they can see how it
could work there are plenty of other
countries that uh are doing it right now
but at present uh we don't think it's
necessary uh to proceed on that on that
basis we think that the uh we can keep
going with uh
all the stipulations that uh i i
mentioned and chris uh reinforced that
we're asking people to to observe uh we
think that's the right balance uh given
where the the data is now uh but you've
got to be you've got to be mindful that
this disease does have a way
of of changing and moving what is what
is
absolutely for certain is the vaccine's
made a vast difference and if you know
the single what people take away from
this uh this press conference above all
it's not perhaps the importance of plan
a or plan b but the
that fixing that gap in the number of
people who have uh had their vaccine of
whatever age and that statistic about uh
the risks to to to an unvaccinated uh 30
year person in their 30s seems to be
very very powerful and i would just you
know the numbers are going up
and it's very encouraging to see how
many people are coming forward to to get
vaccinations and i i would just urge
everybody who you know is still
apathetic about it to to join the club
because it's you know worthwhile
uh steve swinford the times
um professor witty one of the world's
biggest female celebrities nicki minaj
who today publicly linked the coronary
vaccines to impotence now she's got
eight million followers on twitter many
of them are young people the young
people you're suggesting should get
vaccinated what would you say to them
and how concerned are you by public
comments like that from public figures
um prime minister sage and spyen have
both advised that the government that
working from home is one of the single
most effective measures of reducing
transmission but looking at your autumn
and winter plan it's not actually part
of plan b it seems to kind of hover as
some kind of plan c with a decision on
its shelf for a later date when you
actually look at the document why are
you more reticent about deploying
working from home to combat this and one
last question um prime minister a lot of
your cabinet are feeling very anxious
we're gathered here today about their
own futures can you formally rule out a
reshuffle ahead of the conservative
party conference
chris
on the reshuffle
thank you prime minister um
uh so there are a number of myths that
fly around with varying some of which
are just clearly ridiculous and some of
which are clearly designed just to scare
that happens to be one of them uh that
is untrue uh i my own strong suggestion
if i may to uh
uh
media present and not present is
repeating them in public actually just
gives them credence which they don't
need
uh they're untrue full stop uh if you
think about where we are actually
overall and this is this is a slightly
longer answer to your question i think
it's a very important one the great
majority people are getting vaccinated
so the great majority people are
ignoring these myths
and if you talk about people in their
50s and 60s and 70s you're talking about
over 90 people getting vaccinated
and very few people actually are
actively in this in a sense in the
anti-vaxx group
there are a group of people who've got
strange beliefs and fine and they make
their own choices and in a sense also
fine people are adults are allowed to
make their own choices however strange
that is a basic principle of
medical ethics actually
but there are also people who go around
trying to discourage other people from
taking
a vaccine which could be life-saving or
prevent them from having life-changing
uh injuries to themselves
and many of those people i regret to say
i think know that they are peddling
untruths
but they still do it in my view they
should be ashamed
and i'll leave it at that
and i look up just on that steve i'm not
familiar with the works of uh or not as
familiar with the works of nicki minaj
as i probably should be but i am
familiar with with uh nikki kanani a
superstar gp of bexley who's appeared
many times on uh before you uh who will
tell you that vaccines are wonderful and
everybody should get them uh so i prefer
to listen to to nicki kanani and on your
point about about working from home this
is this is one of those things where i
think just
look at what the public are
doing i think people are coming back to
their their offices that you're seeing
the numbers and the numbers that the
time uh
really suggests that people are uh more
confident uh they're getting back into
their their places work for the reasons
i've given many times before i think
that that's a good thing i think that uh
on the whole uh
particularly for younger people uh you
need the social capital you get from the
workplace you need the
the learning from uh from colleagues i i
think that will on the whole be uh be
more productive and and it's fairer to
to everybody if we can if we can do that
but people are also doing are being
sensible and
responsible uh if we have to change the
the guidance that we uh that we give on
on that then uh then we will but that's
that's plan b as uh as you'll have uh
you've heard earlier on
that's the problem i mean the point
about something like working from home
it's about contact patterns and and in a
way this is all quite straightforward
that disease spreads much more rapidly
the more contacts we have and in certain
environments the more contacts you have
are more risky and working from home is
just a way in which contacts inevitably
go down so that's why it was highlighted
as a particularly effective
measure to decrease spread at times when
you have big increases in in levels
thanks
lizzy buck in the
mirror thank you prime minister um
you've spoken about reserving the right
to use vaccine passports and the plan b
document states that they could be
imposed for nightclubs in large venues
but it doesn't entirely rule out
mandated them more widely are you
considering imposing them in pubs and or
would you like to rule that out and to
the scientists uh what are your views on
the evidence behind the use of vaccine
passports um
phe found that they mitigate the risk of
transmission so why are we not using
them now
thanks very very much but uh no i've
lizzie i think i've never been in favor
of of vaccine passports for for pubs
i've i've been i think pretty clear
about that throughout the
the pandemic um but i do think that
there are settings as we as we put it uh
nightclubs uh
large music venues and uh and and so on
the new venues with very with big
closely packed crowds uh where where
they might be uh appropriate as i as we
all know uh some events have been using
them over the summer uh very effectively
to to get going um and i think it would
be sensible sensible for a government
not to to rule that out
um in terms of the question to us i mean
the question about whether it's a
passport is entirely a one for uh
political leaders that's a legitimate
and uh societal one uh from the science
point of view though i think
nobody
would doubt that it's you're safer off
if you go to any indoor venue
where everyone around you is vaccinated
it reduces the probability they will get
covered at all it reduces the
probability if they do have kv they will
pass it on and if everybody in the in
the environment is vaccinated the
transfer mass spreading event is very
substantially reduced because
everybody's got it so things that are to
encourage everybody to get vaccinated
particularly if they're going to large
mass events indoors
you know
the evidence that that is going to be a
good idea uh is is rock solid
uh how that's done is very much a matter
for ministers
good thank you uh adam payne politics
home
prime minister uh a question for you
please on the potential mandating of
vaccine passports uh michael kill who's
the ceo of the night time industries
association told politics home today
that the government's handling of this
issue has been chaotic and that plan b
could force nightclubs and venues to
make massive logistical changes
at a moment's notice what's your message
to michael in that industry and to them
professor witty and sir patrick please
do you have any data on the
effectiveness of the booster shot uh
professor ferguson yesterday said a
study in israel suggested people were 10
times less likely to catch mild disease
after receiving the third dose do i
review having information you can share
on that please
yes sir thanks very much adam on
nightclubs and the whole the whole uh
nighttime economy we want to keep it
open and
the big difference between this year and
last year is that thanks to vaccination
uh we are able to keep it open it's uh
it's a it's a it's a great thing um
we just have to be sensible and and look
at the the risks that uh that we face
and i think that uh
some sort of coping certification uh
system of a kind of plenty of uh venues
have been using already uh might well be
uh sensible uh we're working with the
the industry including the nightclub
industry to make sure that they
understand what could be uh required of
them and
of course i understand uh the
frustrations of people wondering whether
or not they're going to have to to to
put this in at the moment we're
confident uh that you won't that we'll
be able to proceed uh without it but
the choice uh
is and the reason for wanting to have
this option is because it's a choice
that then was seen proceeding with
covered certification or sadly once
again asking uh places to close and i i
certainly don't want uh to do that so
that's why i think uh it's a it's a good
idea to keep this up our sleeve and keep
this in uh in reserve and on boosters i
mean it's very clear that the booster
shots cause a very big increase in
antibody responses and and that would be
expected to have a very big knock-on
effect for uh protection in terms of
infection and and hospitalizations and
death so i think uh the data looked
pretty pretty clear on that what one
just final point and which is on the
first one um i think a lot of people
believe young people aren't taking out
the vaccine not true
the great majority of people uh 16 to 29
have already taken up their first
vaccine and taking up their second so
the idea that this is just a minority of
young younger people who haven't is
completely untrue we should always start
from that basis that's right thanks very
much everybody thank you thank you
well that was the prime minister boris
johnson alongside the chief medical
officer professor chris witte and the
chief scientific advisor sir patrick
valance giving their update on the
winter covid plan
the prime minister outlined plan a which
relies on booster vaccines being rolled
out for the over 50s
and plan b
which he said
is only to come in in certain scenarios
we do not see the need now he said to
proceed with mandatory certification but
it's not sensible to rule out completely
this kind of option now
and that of course plan b is
covered
vaccine certificates for certain
settings mandating face masks in certain
settings asking people to work from home
we are confident the prime minister said
in the vaccines and we're now
intensifying that effort there was a
real boost a real push
from the three gentlemen there to
encourage the five million people who
are eligible for vaccines and haven't
yet had one to take up the offer of a
vaccine also 12 to 15 year olds to be
invited for vaccines and that booster
program the pm described it as building
even higher walls of immunization and
vaccine protection in this country we
are confident he said we can continue
with our plan to turn jabs jabs jabs
into jobs jobs jobs
professor chris witte set out some of
the data he said that cases have been
stabilizing over the past week but we
are going into a difficult period of the
year
hospitalizations have gradually been
drifting up but nowhere near
the peaks of the first and second waves
at deaths the number is significantly
lower compared to case numbers but at
around 140 a day on the seven day
average it is drifting up very slowly 44
million people are now fully vaccinated
on the importance of the vaccination
professor chris woody gave us some
indication he said someone in their 30s
who is unvaccinated is running the same
risk as someone in their 70s who is
vaccinated
we've got a bit more information about
what might trigger plan b from the
scientists as they said they would be
looking
at all of the data they'd be looking at
hospitalizations not just the number but
the rate of change if we started to see
a surge in the numbers of
hospitalizations generally the state of
the nhs everyone knowing that winter is
a difficult time so the relationship
between cases and hospitalizations
and sir patrick valance saying you've
got to go early enough and ensure that
any measures brought in are significant
enough so a word of caution from the
scientific advisors
they were also asked about the rapper
nicki minaj who has been
sending tweets about coronavirus
vaccines they are myths designed to
scare
professor chris whitty said clearly
untrue repeating them in public gives
credence they are untrue full stop there
are many people who said who know they
are peddling on truths and go on doing
it anyway in my view they should be
ashamed of themselves
well let's have a listen now to the
prime minister as he set out his covid
winter plan during that downhill street
news conference
the result of this vaccination campaign
is that we have one of the most free
societies
and one of the most open economies in
europe and that's why we're now sticking
with our strategy in essence we're going
to keep going
and we will keep
further measures
in reserve plan b
we do not see the need now to proceed
for instance with mandatory
certification
but we'll continue
to work with the many businesses that
are getting ready uh such a scheme in in
indeed over 200 events have already used
covid certification voluntarily
and it's it's just not sensible to rule
out completely this kind of option
now
when we must face the fact that it might
still make the difference between
keeping businesses open at full capacity
or not
the prime minister was joined by the
chief scientific advisor officer and the
chief medical officer who emphasized the
importance of getting vaccinated
especially as winter approaches
one of the most depressing things for
doctors
including myself is talking to people
who have just chosen not to get
vaccinated because it wasn't convenient
to that particular moment and you see
them being wheeled down to intensive
care and you know this was a very
serious uh problem as a result of them
not being vaccinated we really must
encourage everybody we know to get
vaccinated the great majority people who
have not been vaccinated not because
they're against vaccination but because
they just haven't got to doing it and
we're about to enter winter winter is
coming and people really should take
this seriously
well the government has released the
latest data about the uk's coronavirus
outbreak there have been a further 26
628
new cases of coronavirus reported in the
latest 24-hour period a further 185
people have died after contracting
covert
that takes the total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test to 134
446.
another 19
428 first doses of a covid vaccine have
been given while 60
653 people received their second dose in
total more than 44.1 million people are
now fully vaccinated against covert 19.
now um
after that news conference i was just
summarizing and gave you some details
about uh professor chris witte when he
was asked about
false information about kovid and the
vaccines being posted on twitter this is
his response to that question
there are a number of myths that fly
around with varying some of which are
just clearly ridiculous and some of
which are clearly designed just to scare
that happens to be one of them that is
untrue there are also people who go
around trying to discourage other people
from taking
a vaccine which could be life-saving or
prevent them from having life-changing
injuries to themselves
and many of those people i regret to say
i think know that they are peddling
untruths
but they still do it
in my view they should be ashamed
our political editor beth rigby is in
downing street for us hello to beth an
interesting news conference with the
prime minister setting out plan a and
plan b and a bit more information from
the scientists
about what might lead us into those
extra measures of plan b
yes sir but i think the thing for me out
of that press conference was when
professor ritti said we've got to really
take it as he it comes he said we've not
faced a winter with delta variants so
these combinations of winter when it's
already more transmissible the nhs
already under stress as we know and this
particular delta variant which we know
is more transmissible well he said we've
just got to see how it goes and that
definitely was the feeling of that press
conference no one uh refusing to rule
anything in or out i think the closest
we got was when the prime minister prime
minister said he really did not want to
have uh covert passports for pubs but as
for everything else well it seems to be
that the government has decided that
they will at the moment really push
for vaccinations they talked about that
six million of us who are eligible
people that haven't been vaccinated and
then of course 12 to 15 year olds from
next week they'll be offered a first
date that's another three million uh
children that could have uh doses of the
vaccine a big push on that in order to
try and prevent all the other options in
that plan b for having to be put forward
that's
mandatory wearing of mass the use of
covered passports
in big venues and of course even the
potential for working at home what was
clear was that there was a sliding scale
if you like of measures all designed to
avoid a potential lockdown the prime
minister saying there as they have said
in the winter plan that they don't think
that that will be necessary with all the
other
tools in the toolkit but refusing to
rule it out and what would be the
trigger while the transmissibility of
the delta variant
and of course a big spike in
hospitalizations and that was what uh
sir chris whittie uh was talking about
that he was looking to what are the
hospital numbers and then of course
what's the link between hospitalizations
and deaths now they didn't put numbers
on it but they certainly said that
that's what they would look at and also
i thought what finally was very
interesting was sir patrick valance when
he was
asked about what could happen
this autumn he said the thing is when
you decide to take a measure you should
go
early and it should be significant
enough now was that a nod to what
happened last autumn when the prime
minister dragged his heels on that
circuit breaker
and then we ended up with all those
regional lockdowns eventually having
that christmas lockdown and then a
three months of lockdown in the new year
so maybe a veiled message there from sir
patrick valance to politicians about not
delaying
if the numbers start going in the wrong
direction
beth thanks very much indeed beth would
be there in downing street this is sky
news coming up faceless unviable and
potentially unlawful prince andrew's
lawyer on the claims of sexual assault
made against him as a lawsuit is
launched by his accuser
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's estimated that around 70 of our
coastlines are experiencing increased
erosion
[Music]
we start with a steel structure that we
put into the seafloor we then pass a
very small electrical current between
what we call an anode and the cathode
and the structure itself is the cathode
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you